ja ich denke der öffentlich-rechtliche
Rundfunk in Deutschland hat zwei
Probleme das eine ist die fehlende
politische Ausgewogenheit und das andere
ist sind eben die hohen Kosten er
verschwendet eben viel von unserem aller
Geld für unseren beitragsgeld das für
alle zahlen müssen die politische
Unausgewogenheit die sieht man wenn man
nur mit einem halben Auge lachten
zweimal hinschaut das ZDF gönnt sich zum
Beispiel ein Komiker namens Böhmermann
der nach dem Motto agiert links von mir
ist nur die Wand wir haben einen ZDF
Kabarett das heißt heute show dass wir
zusammengehalten vom Hass auf die FDP
wir haben ein Jugendprogramm namens Funk
das ist verfilmt der Antifa und wir
haben jede Menge Tagesthemen Kommentare
die man offenbar mit lachen nur im bei
den Grünen gerne anhört das ist das eine
die fehlende politische Ausgewogenheit
das andere was soll ich noch schlimmer
ist sind die horrenden Kosten die unser
System verschlingt das teuerste der Welt
heißt es oft 8,5 Milliarden Euro jedes
Jahr Gebühreneinnahmen Beitragseinnahmen
8,5 Milliarden luxusgehälter davon
werden bezahlt für die Intendanten mehr
als Bundespräsidenten quasi mehr als der
Bundeskanzler was haben wir dafür aber
wir haben jede Menge Sender ARD und wir
haben parallel noch ein ZDF und ich bin
der Meinung wenn es das ZDF nicht gäbe
würde es heute niemand erfinden das ist
die größte Doppelstruktur die wir haben
dass wir neben den
Landesrundfunkanstalten uns noch ein ZDF
gönnen das über 2 Milliarden Euro jedes
Jahr bekommt ich würde sagen sparen wir
uns diese zwei Milliarden machen wir bei
der Verschwendung einen harten Cut und
sparen wir uns das ZDF sollte die WM in
Katar als das letzte große Ereignis sein
wo Aldi und ZDF gemeinsam hinfahren
absolut also ich bin generell der
Meinung wer wer Fußball sehen will oder
andere hochpreisige hochpreisige Sport
Ereignisse der kann auch zu privaten
gehen der kann auch Paypal view machen
bei anderen Sendern warum soll die
Allgemeinheit und wir alle müssen zahlen
jedes Unternehmen muss zahlen jeder
Verein muss zahlen jeder Betrieb muss
zahlen warum sollen wir alle dafür
zahlen ähm das ist das etwas zynisch
jetzt Millionäre in einer halben
Diktatur den Ball hinterher rennen wer
ist schauen mag gerne aber das hat kein
nichts mit dem kernauftrag der
öffentlich-rechtlichen zu tun und diese
Verschwendung diesen Doppelstrukturen
ist einfach glaube ich mit kleinen
kosmetischen Maßnahmen einfach nicht zu
machen jetzt haben wir gerade eben
gehört beim beim WDR der baut auch ein
neues Funkhaus aus da liefen die Kosten
auch aus dem Bruder sollen sich
verdoppelt haben der Landesrechnungshof
für Nordrhein-Westfalen schaut da jetzt
nach beim rbb haben wir noch die
verschwendungsorgien die viele Köpfe
schon haben rollen lassen also ist es
mit kleinen Dosen nicht mehr getan da
brauchen wir eine harte Reform damit das
System als Ganzes erhalten bleiben kann
aber es gibt ja immer einen
Gegenargument wo gesagt wird ich öffne
hier mal die Runde herafelchen es gibt
ja das Gegenargument wo gesagt wird der
Rundfunkbeitrag ist auch eine
demokratieabgabe wir brauchen den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk für die
demokratieabgabe heckes Levels jetzt gar
nicht abschaffen sondern zusammenlegen
wie stehen sie dem Gegenüber sie zahlen
ja wahrscheinlich auch den
Rundfunkbeitrag ist ja Pflicht in
Deutschland das denke ich dass ich das
mehrfach auch gleich so für meine Kinder
mit und alles mögliche andere auch denn
das ist ja das ist ja keine einmalabgabe
ist eine Zwangsabgabe für ein
kollektivsystem das politisch nicht
ausgewogen ist absolut nicht ist eine
absolut tendenzveranstaltung dort das
ist natürlich auch eine selbst Selektion
der Journalisten da müssen sie sich
selbst an die Nase fassen irgendwann mal
wer wird Journalist und wie werden sie
bezahlt beim öffentlichen klar aber die
selbst Lektion bei den öffentlich
rechtlichen meine ich aber da muss man
was dagegen tun und da muss man
eigentlich was dagegen tun das kann
nicht sein wenn es eine
Zwangsabgabe ist die als Kollektiv ein
kollektiven Rundfunksender finanziert
dann müssen die auch entsprechend
repräsentativ
sich reflektieren die Journalisten es
kann nicht sein dass ich glaube 90 oder
95 Prozent der Volontäre grüne Wähler
sind bei Einstellungen oder sonst
irgendwas
eine Umfrage
wahrscheinlich heikel aber
80% reicht ja auch also dass das würde
ich aber das ist jetzt dann rein Meinung
die ich da hätte wobei manche
öffentliche dieses Video BBC zum
Beispiel tut sich Haare gar nicht
schlecht oftmals also es gibt auch
Beispiele wo es gut läuft wir müssen
allerdings da tatsächlich mal drauf
schauen
oder der Rechnungshof ist natürlich
genau der Kontrolleur den wir da auch
einsetzen dazu wir haben doch immer das
Stichwort das ist ja nicht verkehrt
Vielfalt Wirklichkeit die vielfältige
Wirklichkeit soll abgebildet werden in
den Medien dann brauchen wir aber auch
mehr Köpfe die für verschiedene
Meinungen stehen diese Vielfalt dieser
könnte man argumentieren es braucht ad
und ZDF für die Vielfalt verschiedene
Talkshow die ARD allein mit ihren vielen
Landesrundfunkanstalten die kann alles
machen wirklich alles was das tätig
aufmachen kann aber man muss schon bei
der Auswahl man schaut ja auch nach
anderen Kriterien nach der versity dann
kann man auch mal nach einer diversity
of opinion ganz gezielt schauen und
sagen jetzt suchen wir mal auch aus dem
konservativ Liberalen Spektrum einige
Leute und zwar ganz gezielt Frau Robert
schauen Sie gerne in den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk ARD ZDF
ja also bei mir läuft die Augen auf und
mach den Fernseher an und mach die Augen
zu mach den Fernseher aus ich lebe
allein ich wenn ich nicht staubsauge
läuft der Fernseher entweder der
Staubsauger oder der Fernseher so ist es
bei mir und ich bei mir läuft eigentlich
bin Nachrichten Junkie ja es laufen
immer Nachrichtensender weil mich das
wahnsinnig interessiert und ich meine
morgens bei ARD und ZDF ist sowieso drei
Stunden glaube ich das gleiche das
Frühstücksfernsehen keine Ahnung ist
auch immer ziemlich leicht aber das
braucht man auch also es ist eine Flut
von Fernsehsendern weltweit ja da kommt
man gar nicht hinterher dann bin ich
süchtig nach Netflix also nach Serien
und sonst was alles also ich würde auch
sagen also wenn das so ist stimmt ich
zahl auch für ARD und ZDF auch Miss
mutig genauso wie für die Handelskammer
wo ich auch zwangsmitgliedsbeiträge sein
muss und ich brauche jeden Cent für
meine lustigen Lebensstil schauen was
ZDF ab okay
gibt es denn etwas um auch mal was
positives vom Aldi ZDF sagen wo sie
sagen das sind gute Dokumentation oder
die beschäftigen sich wirklich mit den
Themen die ihnen am Herzen liegen oder
hat vielleicht Herr Kistler recht dass
man ARD und ZDF nicht beides braucht ich
glaube dass man heute sehr schauen muss
und seine Informationen aus vielen
Kanälen ziehen kann ich glaube das ist
wichtigste ist eine Konkurrenz gibt die
dann als Konkurrenz gesehen wird und das
Informationen breit gefächert sind es
gibt ja repräsentative Umfragen die auch
sagen dass man heute Medien in Frage
stellt oder Informationen die man
bekommt in Frage gestellt bekommt und
dann glaube ich dass es wichtig ist dass
man auch so eine Ausgewogenheit hat und
auch mal gucken kann ich gucke jetzt mal
bei der ARD ich gucke beim ZDF obwohl es
häufig die gleiche Hausnummer ist und
sie haben vollkommen recht dass manchmal
doppelt sich etwas da fragt man sich
warum habt zwei Sender den gleichen
Sendeplatz und bekommt doch
unterschiedliche Gelder auf der anderen
Seite denke ich doch es gibt viele Dinge
ich gucke sehr viel öffentliches
Fernsehen weil ich glaube dass dort die
Informationen verpackter sind
ausgewogener sind und nicht so Fast Food
information sind wobei mittlerweile
viele private auch sehr gute
Nachrichtensendungen haben das will ich
gar nicht in Frage stellen die Kosten
der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
kostet halt Milliarden im Jahr und das
ist ja viele das was viele stört das
ärgert mich natürlich auch klar muss ich
das auch bezahlen das müssen wir alle
bezahlen und die Frage ist ob das
letztendlich gerechtfertigt ist weil man
eben bei den Privaten die sich über
Werbung finanzieren oder andere
Möglichkeiten haben eben auch bestimmte
Dinge bekommt und ob man das nicht
zusammenschrumpfen kann ich bin sowieso
ein kein Freund davon dass man Gelder
zum Fenster rausschmeißt gerade in einer
Zeit wo man Gelder braucht in vielen
Systemen und ich finde es auch schlimm
dass Menschen überbezahlt werden ob das
jetzt beim Fußball ist oder in der
Politik oder auch im in den Medien das
ist nicht fehlen da muss man auch noch
mal über Fairness nachdenken und da
hilft vielleicht auch dass man darüber
nachdenkt dass man dann aus zwei Sendern
Einsendern macht da muss man am besten
das beste behalten ich meine es gab ja
gerade heute die Umfrage im Tagesspiegel
sollen ARD und ZDF beibehalten werden
haben wir Drittel erlebt ein Drittel
sagt
ganz Deutschland soll so bleiben in
Drittel sagt beide verschmelzen und ein
Drittel gar nicht und wenn wir da die
Parteien Präferenz sich anschaut läuft
es genau zu der These vor den Volontären
hinaus nämlich 46% der Grünen Wähler
also die allermeisten haben gesagt lasst
es genauso wie es ist also ein sehr
konservatives bewahrendes Verhältnis der
Grünen zum öffentlich-rechtlichen sie
merken dort werden sie gut bedient und
das haben sie zurecht gemerkt als grünen
Wähler kann man sich eigentlich nur
freuen wenn man die
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen sich anschaut an
vielen Stellen nicht an allen aber doch
an vielen Stellen es werden einem
Versagens Episoden von Rot Grün
vorenthalten und die auf der anderen
Seite werden einem epischer Breite
ausgewalz insofern würde ich die Grünen
wählen wäre ich bei den Grünen würde ich
sagen lasst es so das heißt eigentlich
sind heute am 2 Lösungsvorschläge einmal
mehr konservative Journalisten oder
libertäre Journalisten
öffentlich abschaffen ich fühle mich
wiedergegeben gut dann muss der
Öffentlichkeit nur noch Alexander
einladen ist das Thema einmal erledigt
er wird das oben sanieren hier meine
empfehl